in an effort to fight climate change the
Sahara Desert could be going green
literally plans are being made to
terraform the entire Sahara Desert
changing it from a dry barren landscape
to a lush green space if successful the
transformation could remove 7.6 billion
tons of atmospheric carbon yearly how
could we change the nature of such a
vast isolated landscape could we afford
the giant price tag that would come
along with it
and have we ever done anything like this
before this is what if and here's what
would happen if we terraformed the
Sahara Desert the Sahara Desert is eight
point six million square kilometres in
size it's roughly the size of America if
you filled America with sand took away
all the trees terraforming an area this
massive wouldn't be easy in fact it
would cost about two trillion dollars a
year and unfortunately the price tag
would just beat the beginning of our
obstacles what kind of environmental
domino effect would this create plants
and trees are the lungs of the earth and
right now we could use a lot more of
them a single hectare of trees can
absorb the same amount of carbon dioxide
you would produce by driving a car for
100,000 kilometres if we could
successfully terraform the Sahara it
would result in millions of hectares of
trees being added to the battle against
climate change that all sounds great but
what are the odds we could pull this
kind of transformation off believe it or
not we already have just on a smaller
scale China's cappucci ecological
restoration project saw the successful
greening of one-third of the cappucci
desert with 70 different plant species
over a 30 year time span how could we
scale that up for the largest hot desert
on earth one idea is to plant crops and
trees and then
pomp desalinated water from the coast of
the Sahara to irrigate them to prevent
evaporation the water would be carried
by underground pipes to reach the roots
directly the ideal things to plan would
be eucalyptus trees since they're Hardy
and they do well in hotter climates plus
they grow quickly and could be
economically beneficial for the region
as the trees began to root and stabilize
the soil would be replenished with
needed nutrients rainfall amounts would
increase and the overall temperature of
the Sahara would cool by 8 degrees
Celsius okay so with time running out in
our fight against climate change why
aren't we moving faster on such a
significant potential solution
[Music]
well first off did we mention that it
would cost two trillion dollars a year
have fun getting international
governments to pitch in on that
especially if it's just for the greater
good of humanity
but even if we could afford it
terraforming the Sahara Desert
would come with its fair share of issues
as the region becomes wetter as a result
of millions of new trees being planted
the risk of locust plagues increases
yeah that's right locusts the swarming
pests best known for their biblical
associations wait locusts can't be that
bad can they well a small swarm eats
more than what twenty five hundred
people can eat in a day so yeah they can
be that bad however the biggest problem
with terraforming the Sahara would be
the environmental domino effect it would
create the Sahara sand gets carried in
the air by wind power and is deposited
in South America after crossing the
Atlantic Ocean the dust picks up
moisture during its journey and when it
falls from the sky rain comes along with
it this dust and rain combo falls on the
Amazon rainforest helping to fertilize
it and providing the ecosystem the water
that it needs no Sahara could
potentially mean no more Amazon
rainforest unless someone else steps in
with a plan to avert that crisis so even
though a green Sahara would
our carbon emissions would it be worth
potentially destroying another part of
the planet maybe instead of terraforming
one giant location we should spread our
greening out around the world but that's
a topic for another what if
[Music]